Who is
the god like Yahweh?
The god of wrath the god of Mercy The
God Who reaches down to unworthy
people.
Well church it is good to see you this morning I'm glad
you came back after last week knowing what we're getting into
with Micah so we are gonna journey through
that it's gonna be hard but it's gonna be good so just dig
in and stay with me we're gonna get started into
the meat of the book now, so if you're not already there go
ahead and turn to the Book of Micah in your copy of
God's word it is in the Old Testament, you can find it
just right of middle somewhere in there. You can find
middle and then turn right bunch a little prophets in there the Book
of Micah
Put a bookmark. There will be there for the next few months as
we get started today, though.
many of you have heard
already that part of my life story involves being
deeply broken over sin at around the age
of 20. So we're welcoming college students. That was a huge part
of my journey as well College was
and
I don't have shared this a lot with you've been here for a while. But but
really this is what God did in my life and so I can't
help but share what he's done in it. She had
grown up in a small town in, Northwest, Oklahoma.
Where all I knew all the right Church
answers and and I had to to kind of expected to
be living a certain way publicly, but it
was not really in my heart at all.
See, I externally I looked alright, I had
I was a good church kid. I was a leader of FCA at school
the whole thing that we do but internally.
I was rebelling against God in the lust of
My Flesh and the pride of my heart.
I thought I was the best at everything. I was pursuing selfishly
all the the desires that I
had and was never really pursuing Jesus
but something changed.
a 20
and you know what it was.
It was finally seeing God for
who he is.
Which then led me to in light of that see my
sin for what it is in comparison to who
he is.
And I take no credit for that. That was God's work in my heart. It
wasn't like I was searching it out. God met me and changed
it and he used a few other people in my life to finally
help me see what repentance actually means.
And it wasn't until that moment that I finally understood the gravity
the weight of sin and how heavy
God's judgment felt.
That I was about to lose everything. I was about to lose the
woman that thankfully is now my wife. I was about to lose football.
I was about to lose future Ministry opportunities. I
was I was heading down a path that with Cliff was on the other side.
I was falling off.
But what that weight of sin also did is
it then magnified how freeing it
felt whenever God washed over
me with his forgiving Grace.
It's like the scales right how low this one got but how
great this one was on the other side of it.
So what we're gonna find today in Micah chapter one.
Is a group of people who had turned their backs on that
same grace and mercy.
Like sheep, they'd gone. Astray. They'd each turned
to their own way along this process and
what we'll learn about God today is how
he views sin like that.
How that Rebellion is seen in his eyes?
And so last week as we started the book we discovered that Micah was
a prophet around 730 BC primarily to
the southern Kingdom of Judah. Remember the Well Done
map, right the southern Kingdom of Judah and and
he was speaking primarily to them with Jerusalem as
it's Capital, but he also referenced the Northern Kingdom of
Israel, which its capital was Samaria. So he he was kind
of mostly South but also to North and so so
he as a prophet his job remember was
to communicate God's words to his
people
Now usually that was judgment on sin, but it also included
God's promises God's assurances. He
was speaking what God Said to the people.
And so what Micah is a collection of those speeches he
would give and so to give us a feel for how God spoke
through Micah. I want to start by reading the entire first chapter of
Micah because we need to understand this
and learn from where they failed and how we
can not fail but also what they did, right and so we
are gonna learn from this by the way, as I read
this reading the names in the Bible is just as difficult
for me. So let's just Journey Through This Together.
This is Micah chapter one. I'm going to start with verse 1
we did last week, but it'll give us some context.
The word of the Lord that came to Micah of morrisheth in
the days of jotham. Ahaz and Hezekiah Kings of
Judah which he saw concerning Samaria and Jerusalem.
Here's what he said.
Here you peoples all of you.
Pay attention. Oh Earth and all that is in it and let
the Lord God be a witness against you the Lord from
his holy Temple behold. The Lord is coming out
of his place. He will come down and tread upon
the eye places of the Earth.
And the mountains will melt under him The Valleys
will split open like Wax before the fire like Waters
poured down a steep place.
All this is for the transgression of Jacob for
the sins of the House of Israel. What is the
transgression of Jacob? Is it not Samaria?
What is the high place of Judah is it not Jerusalem?
Therefore I will make Samaria a heap in the Open Country
a place for planting Vineyards. I'll pour down
her stones into the valley uncover her foundation.
All her carved images shall be beaten to Pieces all
their wages shall be burned with fire and all
their Idols. I will lay waste.
For from the fee of a prostitute she gathered them and to the
fee of a prostitute they shall return.
For this I will lament and wail. I
will go stripped and naked I'll make lamentation like the jackals morning
like the ostriches.
For her wound is incurable. It has come to Judah.
It has reached to the gate of my people to Jerusalem.
Tell it not in gas weep. Not
at all in best La Afra roll yourselves
in the dust pass on your way inhabitants of
shafir in nakedness and shame.
The inhabitants of Za Anan do not come
out.
The lamentation of Beth Ezell shall take
away from you. It's standing place.
For the inhabitants of moroth wait anxiously for good.
Because disasters come down from the Lord to the gate of Jerusalem.
Harness, the steeds to the Chariots inhabitants of lakeish. It
was the beginning of sin to the daughter of Zion for
in you were found the transgressions of Israel.
Therefore you shall give parting gifts to more shift gas.
The houses of axib shall be a deceitful thing to the
Kings of Israel.
I will again bring a conqueror to you inhabitants of Marisha the
glory of Israel shall come to adullam.
Make yourselves bald and cut off your hair for the children of
your Delight make yourself as bald as the eagle
for they shall go from you into exile.
So as we look at what God is saying here in this
first chapter our first step here is to understand some truths
about them. Like we we take them first. We
look at the context. What does it mean there? First of
the people involved actually here both Israel and
Judah but also what it teaches about God.
By the way, anytime you see the word as you're reading the Bible the word
Lord or God in in all caps, but small
anytime. You see that it's referring
to Yahweh.
That's God's covenant name. Remember that Exodus 3
shows. He revealed to Moses Moses. Like what do I
tell them your name? Is? He says tell him I'm Yahweh. I
am.
That's his personal Holy Name. The one who chose Israel
to be his possession to be his representative
on the earth. He said that's who I am.
Tell everybody who it is.
So this is Yahweh who's being referred to here that little
caps, right? And so what we learn right away in verses 2 through
4. Is that this Yahweh. He is God.
Yahweh is God and you're like, yeah, I know.
Okay. Well, it's simple I know but you see the picture of who
God is here.
He says here. He's God over all people. He's
God over all the Earth. He's over everything that's
in it, which means if he is that then
we must submit to him.
And you see how huge he really is in verse
4.
Right the mountains melting the valley splitting
students. I was thinking about this. It's like when we were driving a student Camp,
you're going through all those mountains all that imagine those all just
melting down around us.
Into the valleys and becoming a flat plane.
That's the essence that because God was walking on top of the
mountains that's happening. That's the image we get of who
Yahweh. God is
yet.
Even though he is God.
What we learn is that Judah and Israel still rebelled against
him.
That's God. That's the picture of God yet.
they rebelled
verse 5 says Israel rebelled against him by transgressing his
Commandments by making Samaria their
place of worship in the northern kingdom. It was supposed
to be Jerusalem where the temple was but they said no we're going
to do it in Samaria.
So that was their transgression. But yet in verse 5
Micah says the same thing about Jerusalem. He says
Jerusalem is the high place of Judah. That's
a derogatory term.
It means false worship was happening there just
like it was in Samaria.
You see in verse 9 it says the wound this
this scar scourge of sin
has come to Judah.
It has reached to the gate of my people to Jerusalem.
Same in verse 12. There's disaster coming because of
this in Jerusalem. That means Judah is
not immune to the same thing that's happening
in the northern kingdom because what was happening is that
as the northern kingdom was experiencing this this
judgment of God and the Assyrians
were coming into their land. They're starting to get taken over
the people in the south in Judah. They're watching
Fox News and they saw man. Look what's happening in the north. Look
the judgments coming. The judgment is coming. We're
okay because we have Jerusalem
But that leads us to another truth to learn here about God is that Yahweh
is Holy.
Yahweh is Holy
now when we hear that word in our day today, we
think we think sinlessness perfection.
That's not wrong, but that's not actually what it
meant. Originally. It means separated.
it means other
distinct
Like when you go to Grandma's house and the China is in that special cabinet
over there. Nobody ever touches it it's different. It's distinct. It's
held apart, right? That's the idea of holy
is different. So we say God is Holy.
We mean he is completely different than we are.
He's set apart from us the image
we get of being up on the mountain. He's up there. We're down here.
It's the whole theme of the this series
right the Mountaintop who can ascend
He is out. There. We are here.
In verses 2 and 3 we see Yahweh coming out of
his holy Temple, which is apparently up on the Mountain of God because he
comes down.
And Treads upon the high places of
the earth which can be in both size and like elevation mountains
and also false worship.
He treads on top of it.
He's holy.
In fact, he then calls his people to be holy and Leviticus 20
verse 26. He says be holy as I am
Holy not just perfect sinless. He says I
am distinct. You need to be distinct in your Worship
in your actions. This is who I've called you
and set you apart.
to be
yet.
They still turn to idols.
Yahweh is Holy yet. They
knowing he who he
is and what they're called to be. They still turned to idols.
It's vividly described here in verse 7.
He says all her carved images shall be beaten
to Pieces. All her wages shall be burned with fire all her
Idols. I will lay waste.
For from the fee of a prostitute she gathered them to the
fee of prostitute they shall return.
Earmuffs on that one, right? But anytime anytime you
see that kind of language in Scripture.
It has to do with how God's holy people
polluted themselves with idolatry.
with false worship
that they began to worship other nations Gods which
aren't really Gods by the way, they began to worship and in doing
so they broke the Covenant that God had made with them at the
mountain of Sinai with Exodus the
whole scene with Moses up on the mountain. That's the Covenant they
made which by the way some people see that Mountain scene as
like a marriage covenant like a wedding ceremony where
God takes his bride Israel and
and initiates this Covenant with them.
It's like when you go to a wedding, right you've been to a wedding before and you you see
that vows are made between the two parties,
right a wedding is not just an excuse to party
and eat cake. That's not what a wedding is for.
We celebrate what has happened that commitments are made
between the groom and the bride, right?
You've seen it before they stand I take you and for richer
poor till death do us part like that whole thing back and
forth, right?
It's laying out commitments that are made
in the marriage covenant.
That I promise this and you promise this and so thinking spiritually
now if that's what happened at Sinai for
these people when Israel and Judah went after all these
other gods. They worshiped Idols. What they
were doing is they were in essence committing spiritual adultery.
Saying forget the Covenant we want this.
But they'd forgotten something.
Since Yahweh is God since he's
holy Above All Else. He is worthy of
submission to him. That means he's the judge too.
He always also the judge.
And as he looks at their choices.
To try to find some benefit from these false gods
to pursue intimacy elsewhere in their lives.
He sits back and judges it to be sin.
In fact the word used in verse 5. He says it's transgression.
Which when you look back to the original Hebrew language for that word, it means Rebellion.
It means Revolt. It's a
defiants of authority. It's like when you you know, you've seen
that image of somebody shaking their fists and I'm never gonna do right. That's
the image. We get of the word transgression here. It's
not just missing the mark. They had
the audacity to spit in the face of God
almighty.
That's the that's the essence of sin. It's
not just missing the market. It's saying to your father. You can't
tell me what to do.
utter rebellion in essence
that's why they deserved God's judgment.
Yahweh is the judge and they deserved God's judgment.
Again verses 6 and 7 he says it.
I'll make Samaria. That's the Northern Kingdom capital a
heap in the Open Country a place for planting
Vineyards meaning like a flat land. I'll pour
down her stones in the valley uncover her foundations. I'm going
to turn the whole city upside down basically all are carved
images. She'll be beaten to pieces or wages burned with fire. All
our Idols. I will lay waste that is Judgment language.
now here's one of the Tendencies the modern church has
is we tend to
We tend to sugarcoat.
The Judgment of God and we we rush past it
really fast to get to the mercy to try to soften the
blow.
But remember what Micah was doing here.
He's he's watching.
Looking at these supposed Covenant people of God.
Those who were designed to reflect God's
image and they were out there prostituting themselves.
And Micah's job was not to make people feel
better.
Micah's job was not to tell them 10 steps to have
a better life.
His job was not to butter them up and tell them
how great they are and just a firm them and everything. No his job. As
a profit was to communicate hard truths to God's people.
That God is concerned not just with how
the Sinners out there lived their lives.
He's concerned with how his people lived their
lives.
probably even more so
than those out there.
And so Micah's message here was that God's people had
turned away from God and they were
worthy deserving of his judgment.
So that was for them, right? We look at this context for them first, but
then the question is what about us?
Like what do we need to understand now as we look at this and
how do we process this? How do we apply it? Because we're not
Israel or Judah. How do we bring this?
2700 years ahead to where we are today.
What do we now to understand now? Well first we clearly
see this.
Remember that sin is consequential.
Right here. You see it sin has consequences.
If God is Holy if God is perfect then
our Rebellion against him will bring Carnage.
Because it's not the way we were designed to live. He designed
us to live according to his plan and his way and if
we don't do that, it's going to bring something bad. It's not
going to go well and here we see sin brings Eternal
destruction if we don't repent and if we don't turn
to him because we're still under that judgment if that's the
case.
Sin has consequences eternally,
but not only that.
And we see consequences around us every single day.
Don't we?
We feel it in our bodies. The consequences of sin is includes our
physical death. Like we're we're falling apart physically that's
because of sin, but also there's so many
things we can point to as consequential.
Think of that drunk driver who takes someone else's life,
but they make it through somehow.
Or when you gossip around your kids or around
your coworkers and you're poisoning their heart
towards that person you're talking about.
Someone abuses their spouse and goes to jail for decades
and everybody including the kids are traumatized by
the whole experience.
The adultery that you thought would bring you
happiness satisfaction.
Just bring sorrow and misery and
your family and even in your own life.
unforgiveness
causes your inner life to just implode and it fractures relationships
all over the place.
your pornography addiction
Or even just watching sketchy shows at night, right
you you cut your spouse down at the knees and
then you open the door that your kids might even see something and
find something and you open the door to that.
Like this is what Micah 1:16 says the very last
verse of this chapter. He's talking about them mourning because
of what's happening to their children. That's the realities
that sin has consequences not only in your
life, but also in friends and family around you
even in generations to come after you
See, we don't think about that.
When we're experiencing the temporary pleasures of sin.
We don't think about what's going to come from that but hear
me even hidden sin has affects generationally.
So the next truth fits accordingly here.
Lament is appropriate.
Sin is consequential. Absolutely but lament then is appropriate
for it.
Like we need to remember that lament is appropriate for all the
sin and judgment that we see in our lives and see around us.
That's what Micah's doing when he lists all these funny names
in the back half of chapter one. He's doing exactly this.
I'll explain those in a second, but don't miss how he
starts in verse 8.
How he begins this second section here, he says for this what's
he talking this? That's all the Judgment he just talked about.
For this I will lament and wail, I'll go stripped
and naked I'll make lamentation like the jackals and
morning like the ostriches. It's kind of
a weird phrasing there and I don't suggest you go in your
backyard and nakedly scream like a animal you probably
get arrested like don't do that.
But Micah is watching Israel and
Judah destroy themself.
And he could have sat back. He could
have stepped back in judgment himself over
what he was seeing.
remember Jonah
with the ninevites. He said he sits back and he
looks self-righteously and judgment over them and he cackling
over their demise and
he's like, yes, here we go. They're gonna get it now and he's doing it.
Michael could have done the same thing, but he didn't right.
Micah felt it with them.
He felt it with them. He he entered
into their suffering. He lamented that
God was planning the Judgment. He was planning.
He saw it. He felt it and he lamented that's
what he's doing in in verses 10 through 15 all these
names he mentions.
That was a list of towns and cities that he could
see from his hometown of Maura chef.
It's like you go on Rural Oklahoma, right? You can see all those tiny
little towns dotting The Horizon especially at night you're
up on a hill you can see stuff. He was looking as
he stood on his rooftop. Maybe he
saw these tiny towns and he was envisioning what
God was about to do.
in the area
and he lamented
he mourned over the loss and what he did
interestingly. This is kind of a bit of a side note. He used
play on words for all of these names.
He took the names meaning of this this town the meaning
of it and he made a lament or a curse
out of it. If you really go study the language of this you can get
all kinds of it, but I want to give you a couple examples in verse 10. He says
Beth Afra.
That word means House of dust. He
said go roll yourselves in the dust.
For lament right to go more and like that in
verse 11 shaffir that word means beautiful.
He says actually they're going to become the opposite. They're going
to become a town of Shame.
And you go through all of almost all of those names you find how
he plays the word on it, but the point again all
of this.
The point of it is bookended by verse 8 and
verse 16 where there's the shaved head morning picture, right?
They're mourning. What's about to come and Exile? He
is lamenting over the Judgment that's
about to come.
So here's the question.
How do you respond?
When you hear about God's judgment
coming.
What do you think just rhetorically think
about this? What do you think when you hear that God is a god
of mercy and a god of
wrath.
What crosses your mind first first think about
yourself?
Think think about your own.
Sin, do you lament your own
sin?
Like when I got to the age of 20 and finally got
to that point of Brokenness does your sin hurt you?
Do you feel what sangria 7:10 says
do you feel a Godly grief about what
you've done that leads you to repentance?
Listen if you don't
If sin doesn't hurt you.
If you don't feel it inside of you if your heart
is cold, if your heart is hard your heart is
insensitive to the conviction of God's spirit on
you when you sin then you should be concerned.
That's how that's how Judah and Israel God in
this mess and Micah to begin with.
They continue refused the Judgment the
conviction of God, they refused it over and over again until they
finally just got so hard that there was even child sacrifice
happening.
That's how they got the mess. Don't let that happen to you. You need
to wake up. You need to see your head
in the wrong direction and if you don't repent and turn you deserve
judgment, too.
So start checking your heart first about what you feel over
your sin, you know you sin we all do every single
day. So when you don't feel anything about that, that's a problem,
but then there's another heart check here.
When you hear about God's judgment coming on someone else.
How do you respond?
When someone else when on others because they're
sinning God's judgment is coming. Does that cause you
to Lament?
Or do you stand back?
Self-righteously cheering go get them God.
finally
go get them.
They deserve it.
Or do you stand back like Micah?
And grieve it.
Now can we be thankful when evil is removed from the world?
Yes.
But we should never celebrate someone's Eternal
destruction.
Should we not instead mourn that they
are headed to an eternity without God in a place
called hell?
Should we not agonize over someone
who who seemingly is walking away from Jesus
with a hardened heart and it seems like they're heading
that way should we not grieve and agonize and lament over
that? Should we not do that in our own heart
over? What's happening is someone else if we don't then I
don't think we care.
Which then is a really bad place for our hearts to be right?
So lament is appropriate.
When we're faced with sin in our own lives, it's
appropriate. But even when faced with sin in
other people's lives, we should grieve over that.
And it should lead us to action in response, right?
But here's the thing.
Where does all this lead?
Sin, is consequential lament is appropriate where
does this lead? We've seen the nature of God the consequences of
sin and the lament that we need to have.
Okay. Well, what's our final conclusion
that where does this all get us to?
It gets us to the fact that we see clearly Mercy is
needed.
If this is the picture that Micah one paints us.
And we know sin is consequential. We know
that we need to lament it.
We know then also that Mercy is desperately needed.
because again on our own
we're headed to judgment.
And we have no way out that we can't fix it. So Mercy is
the only answer because that word mercy what it means is that
you don't get what you deserve.
That's the difference Grace is gift right Grace
is you get something you don't deserve.
Mercy
Is you don't get what you do? Absolutely deserve.
You get mercy and that is what our
desperate hope is in is in the
mercy that we believe God truly is what
he says. He is in Exodus 34 Verse 6. He says I'm
a God who is merciful and gracious slow
to anger abounding instead fast. Love
that Hess said love from last week, right and faithful.
I'm abounding in that. I'm overflowing in
that. Yes. He's a god of judgment yet. He's also a
god of Mercy.
This is what we need.
So here's what happens when I start talking about this when
any preacher or any one reads through things like
this and we hear about the Judgment of God people start to think and
we look at this and we think that's not
fair.
judgment, like
I mean, it's a valid question, right? How can a good God?
Bring destruction, how how could he ever do
this as he really good? All those questions start to roll.
It's not fair that God would send someone to hell for
that little thing.
I think it's the wrong question though.
Because what's not fair, it's Mercy.
Right, it doesn't add up.
When you think about it, it is not fair because again what
we deserve is judgment and so we get
what we deserve that's fairness, right? That's that's fair.
but Mercy
means that the judge himself provided away for us
to ascend His Holy Hill forever.
That's not fair. We deserve this and he gave us
something else. He didn't give us what we deserve. That's not
fair.
And here's how he provided that way.
He provided that way because where we turn to Idols Jesus
obeyed it perfectly in our place.
Where we failed and deserved his judgment Jesus
took it for us. He made a
way he made a substitute a replacement so
that we could come to him. It's
not fair, but Jesus did it for us.
And what he did is he drank that Cup of Wrath to the very
bottom?
And he shed his blood to be the vessel
of reconciliation and restoration
for us that we could be reconciled back
to God where we were once separated. He drew us
back to him. That's the good news of the Gospel friends.
That's why we can rejoice and celebrate even
knowing God's a god of judgment.
But again remember this
Mercy is only as great
as the problem it solves.
You see what I mean?
I've got this $5 debt to my son and and he
says don't worry about it.
Okay.
Great.
I move on about my way.
But the greater the problem the greater the debt.
the more glorious Mercy is
And we had an eternal debt that we could not pay.
There was no way for us to fix it.
It's only sweet to us when we
begin to recognize how far from God
that we really were.
And the more that that sinks the depths
and heaviness of our sin the more glorious his
Mercy begins to show up in our hearts.
That's what worship comes from. That's what obedience comes
from. That's what
Proclamation of the Gospel comes from is when we recognize what he
has done for us. This is how great our
God is church. This is how much he loves you
that he would do this unfair thing
and take on the Judgment himself.
And so if you feel far from him right now.
Like if you have a ton of sin in your life, and there's no
way God could love me.
Turn back to him today.
You've seen it. This is his answer to the judgment.
It's Mercy.
And doesn't matter how much?
He's going to be a God who is abundant.
In Mercy overflowing in Mercy. He
is a God who is merciful and gracious slow to
anger abounding instead fast, love and faithfulness.
So if that's where you are today, turn back to him run
back to him. That's how you get healthy again.
That's how you respond when he convicts you in
your heart when you know, you're far from God and you're starting to feel that don't
run away from it run to him and rest in
his Mercy.
As you give him his give him your whole heart rest in
him.
He's good.